I wasn't old enough to understand what
was going on during Watergate
what year was that
well 70 so you know the break-in happens
in the lead-up to the 72 election and
then he eventually resigns after that
but this is our Watergate yeah at this
moment right now Cohen's gonna go to
jail for three years and I mean he's
testifying against Trump and all these
people are testifying and they're
calling him what do they call him
co-conspirator number one is that the
individual official individual number
one this is a very unusual moment for us
to be watching this all unfold and to
see this slow dissection what Mueller
seems to be doing is like slowly closing
off all the escape routes
yeah and slowly circling the troops
around this one area that he's trying to
that he's that he's attacking yeah so
I'm he's a brilliant tactician yeah and
and and so I think it's clear that the
worst for Donald Trump is yet to come
and I do think the parallel is Watergate
but there's a really important
difference here you know um so I'm old
enough to remember while at Watergate I
was like 12 or 13 when this happened and
my uncle happened to be the lawyer who
worked in the House of Representatives
convincing the House of Representatives
to vote the articles of impeachment so
he and that weekend when Nixon resigned
he came to visit us we lived in the
Kentucky part of Pennsylvania the kind
of right-wing middle part of the state
he came to visit us and he told me this
was going to happen and that was the
event that was the weekend that I
decided I wanted to become a lawyer um
but but the big difference between these
two times is that when that happened the
way most people got access to news was
three television networks every day they
watched the news at the same time
because there was nothing else on
and those three television networks kind
of shot right down the middle and told
the story as they saw it you know it's
kind of the Walter Cronkite era of news
and as this story broke they just
reported it as they saw it and as they
saw it it was a pretty damning
indictment of the president and what's
amazing is he watched the polling among
Republicans in their support for the
president six months before the
president resigns the poll says among
Republicans he has about an 83 percent
support rate and then when he resigns
his support rate about Republicans is
about 50% and that's because the news
newspapers and television had like told
everybody the same story and Americans
hearing the same story came to the same
view that there was something deeply
corrupt about this president he had to
go we don't live in that news
environment today we live in an
environment where half of America lives
in one news world and the other half
America lives in another news world and
the half of America living in the
Breitbart Fox News world are not being
told the stories that the people living
in the MSNBC NPR news Universe are and
so in this world the opportunity for
Americans to like see the facts the same
facts and have a reflective judgment
about and and come to a view that this
president you know needs to resign or be
impeached I don't think you should be
impeach but let's that's a separate
question is is not possible and that's
what's so terrifying about it when you
live in a democracy where we don't all
live in the same universe you know right
we don't know the same facts how do you
knit together a public that can address
these critical issues of national import
and and that's I think our biggest
challenge right well it gets greater
than that right with characters like
sean hannity that they separate the line
between not just being some sort of a
political pundit but actually
campaigning for the president showing up
at speeches addressing the crowd making
making these big statements in support
of the president it's very strange to
watch because i don't remember that at
the only point in time no it wasn't the
past but i think the thing we need to
realize is it is the future because it
pays cable news pays tremendously when
these people become partisan hacks
inside of a politics of hate which is
the current politics of like
the Democratic member of publican
parties and the cable news stations they
build tribes who are deeply loyal to
them and the loyal to those tribes
translates into advertising dollars it
is the business model of cable so Sean
Hannity looks to you know old geezers
like me like an abomination from the
perspective of what news should be like
but from the standpoint of what the
future is gonna be he is the future and
so then it becomes a question like how
do we knit together a democracy given
there will be people like the Sean
Hannity's on cable television
and you know I've begun to talk about
the slow democracy movement which I
think you know I think I pointed to you
as part of that I think that there's a
need to begin to think about how do we
build political understanding not to
broadcast television but through
something else that gives people a
chance to think in more than 30 second
bites yes and podcasting I think is a
core part of that is it entirely
possible that something could be
profitable that does shoot down the
middle because people are so tired of
this CNN Fox bipolar distribution of
information I mean I remember when the
elections were going on I would flip
back and forth between the two channels
and it was like two alternative
universes there were different worlds
yeah different worlds of focus different
worlds of what they're projecting yes
sir but I don't think the point is that
it has to be down the middle right I
think it has to be deep so this is what
I think is so powerful about podcasting
like you know the fact that you get
people to listen to you talk about an
idea for an hour two hours of them three
hours is astonishing
literally astonishing in an age where
the most a cable news channel will
allocate to a news story is a minute and
a half two minutes three minutes right
and you know in the context of like the
tweet thinking of cable news they can't
afford to go deep on anything and
everything they're going to talk about
are the things they can talk about
sensibly in 25 seconds or 30 seconds or
40 seconds and what you know because
you've lived this life of like having
deep conversations about things that are
important is that it sometimes takes
more than 30 seconds to understand
something always yeah and the point is
if we have media that's focused at the
thirty-second chunk and that's how
America understands the issues we're
never gonna get anywhere and the only
way to get to get someplace is to begin
to have conversations that are at the
hour-long chunk or the two-hour long
Chuck and it's not important that that
be neutral or balanced I don't care if
it's balanced I care that it is
attempting to be serious and in-depth
understanding the issue so I don't care
if Cato wants to have podcasts they try
to tell us the deep story of ein Randy
and economics or something like that
that's fine that's good I think it's
important that people start thinking
about these issues in a richer deeper
way and I think the challenge we have
now is how do we begin to produce
understanding realizing that the world
of Walter Cronkite is never coming back
and it might be a good thing but it is
just never coming back and the world of
Sean Hannity is a world that will
destroy democracy so how do we rebuild
democracy outside of that and you know
if you if you had to pick the three
things that are the most hopeful I think
podcasting is number one I think some of
a reflective deep you know funny playful
but in the end at the end of the
hour-long segment of a podcast you
understand something you didn't
understand before I think that's number
one I think comedy like comedy
television like brings people into
understanding things in a way that's not
possible on Fox News I think that you
know that's number two I think shows
like homeland you know right so watched
it until the red yeah I know and then it
went through this dark period in the
middle but the recent seasons are just
un-fuckin'-believable really and because
they're unbelievable because they are
such a deep rich understanding of the
tensions at issue like you want to
understand the Iran nuclear deal watch
the last season because after watching
that season you like to understand the
tensions between the CIA and the
president and what's actually going on
with Israel and and I think that if you
imagine television shows aspiring to
tell the story in an entertaining way in
a way that brings people in there that
they voluntarily want to watch it but
that in the end at the end of watch
season you understand something I
understand the current seasons about the
Russia you know struggle and I can't
wait to watch it because it's going to
be a richer understanding of that story
than anything on television